patrice evra fue una pieza fundamental
en la defensa de la selección francesa
de fútbol por más de 20 años pero recién
ahora ha surgido otro lado de su
historia un capítulo oscuro durante su
adolescencia que nadie ni siquiera su
madre conocía o cuyos personal hay
muchas cosas que me han pasado en la
vida y que nunca he comentado ni
siquiera a mis padres va a ser una
sorpresa muy grande para ellos y no una
bonita porque en un libro no solo hay
cosas buenas pack de ever sold como
niega por primera vez se verá confesó
que en su adolescencia fue víctima de
abuso sexual en una entrevista para el
diario inglés times que tenía acceso
exclusivo a su libro evra dijo lo
siguiente me daba vergüenza admitir que
había sido abusado sexualmente pero no
quiero que otros niños sientan lo mismo
el abuso sucedió cuando tenía 13 años en
ese entonces evra vivía con un profesor
tres noches por semana
evra cuenta que cuando el profesor
pensaba que estaba dormido metía sus
manos debajo de las sábanas y trataba de
tocarme hacia lo posible para quitarme
los calzoncillos
evra convenció a su madre que le permita
vivir en otro lugar sin contarle por qué
quienes apoyan a las víctimas de abuso
sexual dicen que su confesión podría
impulsar a otros a hacer lo mismo con su
gente conocida da la cara a las víctimas
se sentirán menos solas les parecerá más
fácil encontrar el coraje para contar su
verdad pero para el futbolista lo más
difícil fue contarle del abuso a su
madre más de dos décadas después